did you take part in the vote last night
I I did um I didn't see all of the
rgbaji that's been reported um I saw
some of it in members Lobby and
certainly
um could could feel the uh pressure that
conservative MPS are under and
ultimately so many of them Buckle to put
party before constituency and Country
but I I guess the thing all I'd say this
morning is that it's really not about
the psychodrama of the conservative
party it's about the consequences of
this chaos for the country for people
whose mortgages are going up whose bills
are going up for the big crises in our
country like the crisis in the NHS the
biggest in its history going unaddressed
that's the consequence of this chaos and
that's why today in his speech the TUC
Kia's farmer is setting out Labor's
plans for the economy to get growth
going to tackle the cost of living
crisis and I'm here in Greater
Manchester talking to Health Service
leaders about Labor's plan to arrest the
crisis in the NHS and make it fit for
the future to give people confidence
that in contrast to this rabble of the
government we see with the conservatives
there is a credible government in
waiting to be led by kirst armor this
motion was brought by labor it was never
about fracking you wanted to give the
Prime Minister a bloody nose so how much
responsibility does labor have to take
for what happened yesterday
well this is this is very much about
fracking and it is about the
irresponsible short-termest choices that
the conservatives are making it's also
about holding the conservatives to their
own Manifesto which seems to have gone
out the window and it will take
responsibility for many things we'd love
to have the responsibility of being in
government by the way that's for the
voters to decide at the next election
but we're certainly not going to take
responsibility for the rebel that we see
and calling itself a government and and
and this is the kicker Liz trust may be
gone in days she may be gone in hours
and then what we get another
conservative MP another arsonist who
helped to start the fire now pretending
they're going to be the fire brigade I
don't think so I think people know now
that we need not to change a prime
minister we need we need a change in
government and that's why we are Keen
especially this morning and throughout
the coming days of weeks to emphasize
we're not just about attacking the
shambles of a government we have a
serious alternative a serious leader
with a serious plan and a serious team
to deliver it except your plan failed
you were looking for a sidewall Tory
rebellion and it didn't happen they
filled it in behind her
well and voters will remember that at
the next election I mean how dare these
conservatives who stood on a Manifesto
against fracking who made solemn pledges
their constituents who've been writing
to their constituents in recent weeks to
outline their principled opposition
crumbling uh in the face of
um a shambolic number 10 where we don't
even know if the chief whip is still in
post or not I mean I mean for goodness
sake guys grow a backbone stand up for
your constituents stand up for your
country and given the shambles we've
seen in recent days and given the fact
that so much of the pain people are
feeling in their pockets is as a direct
consequence of the choices that Liz
truss made when she came in why are
conservative MPS tolerating this what
more will it take for them to put their
constituents in their country before
their party
um I don't know and frankly they're out
of time they're out of ideas and and I'm
afraid the public are out of patience
and that's why working to demonstrate
that labor has a serious plan unaltered
alternative that people can have
confidence in and don't just take my
word for it the chairman of Tesco was
saying last weekend wasn't he that when
it comes to economic growth there's only
one team on the pitch and that's labor
yeah and every little helps but you know
what um
they've got another two years uh in uh
Power if they so choose and the Prime
Minister says she has a plan
I mean I mean the Prime Minister can say
What She Likes she's not going to be
there for much longer actually and and I
think people know that there are there's
lots of big challenges going on in the
world at the moment and the voters will
be willing to cut the government some
slack on things like the war in in
Ukraine and the consequence that has for
our country but they will not forgive or
forget the fact that ideological Dogma
from Liz truss cheered by conservative
MPS let's not forget when she went ahead
with this Kamikaze budget has led to
them seeing direct increases in their
mortgage costs in their bills we've got
business slamming the brakes on
investment because the UK looks like a
basket case and that's why kids setting
out our plan for the economy to help
working people that's why I'm here today
talking about how I will deliver the
biggest expansion or one of the biggest
expansions of the NHS Workforce in
history to grip the crisis we see with
the biggest backlogs but also to make
the NHS fit for the future because we
want people to know that in the face of
this rabble there is an alternative and
we're not sat here with our feet up
um enjoying the chaos in in government
we're preparing for government and we're
serious about the challenge and and
frankly we're worried we're worried
about what we're going to inherit
because every day these guys are in
office making more disastrous decisions
our challenge becomes that much greater
and the pain that people are feeling in
their pockets and they and the agony
that families and businesses are going
through will worsen so my message to
conservative MPS today is get a grip and
then get out of the way call a general
election let's let's let the people
decide who they trust to government and
and let the people decide uh who they
trust to give Britain the fresh start
that it deserves but but why on Earth
you know given what the polls are saying
why on Earth would they do that it'd be
like uh turkey's waiting for Christmas
well well indeed and I think that is the
danger that this government just
staggers on you know like a drunken
sailor lurching from one side of the
street to the other you know picking
fights and scraps along the way as we
literally saw
um in the Palace of Westminster last
night I think Britain deserves better
than this and I'd just say it's
conservative MPS if you think things
can't get worse than this in the polls
you be careful what you wish for
um I I think their responsibility now is
to get a grip and then get out of the
way call a general election put your
Manifesto to the people seek a fresh
mandates your breaking promises left
right and center and then people can
compare the conservatives record with
Labor's plan and only the country can
win in that in that scenario
okay um always good to see you West
Street team thanks very much